В ефірі новини дня «heute 19 Uhr» з Яною Парайґіс.
Раді вітати вас у студії.
Про новини спорту, як завжди, розповість
Норберт Леман. Добрий вечір.
А тепер до актуальних новин.
Вся увага прикута до українських портів.
Надія для України й світу.
Президент Зеленський заявив,
що перші кораблі із зерном готові відчалювати.
Нові правила заповнення газосховищ.
Рівень заповнення має збільшитися.
Та чи можливо досягти цієї мети?
Починається полювання за кубком.
ФК «Боруссія Дортмунд» у матчі проти ФК «Мюнхен 1860»
сподівається на гру без несподіванок.
Вперше з початку війни чорноморські порти України
поновлять роботу.
Сьогодні або завтра розпочнеться експорт зерна.
Кораблі готові відчалювати.
Після напружених переговорів
минулого тижня Україна та Росія
підписали угоду про транспортування зерна.
Про підготовку знає більше
Франциска фон Тізенгаузен.
Хмара пилу здіймається
над турецьким вантажним судном,
поки на нього завантажують зерно.
Від початку війни судно
пришвартоване в порту Чорноморська,
що на південному заході від Одеси.
Тепер корабель нарешті може знову покинути порт.
Так зазначив президент України
у присутності послів G7.
Наша сторона готова.
Про це ми повідомили нашим партнерам,
представникам Об'єднаних Націй і Туреччині.
Наші військові гарантують безпеку.
Україна ще чекає від ООН підтвердження
безпечності «зернових коридорів».
За українськими даними,
16 суден вже заповнені зерном
вагою понад 500 тис. тонн.
Загалом планується експорт 20 млн тонн.
«Зернова угода» передбачає відчалювання суден із зерном
з трьох портів Одеської області
через Чорне море та протоку Босфор
і до портів призначення у всьому світу.
Там вже давно чекають на зерно.
Генеральний секретар ООН наголошував на тому,
що ця угода важлива не лише для України.
Вона допоможе
попередити глобальну продовольчу кризу.
Для України продаж зерна є
важливим джерелом доходу.
Адже треба підготувати резервуари до нового урожаю,
який вже на підході.
Ми щойно побачили,
що кораблі готові, але чому вони ще не відчалили?
Анна Брюль зараз в Одесі.
Тож, Анно, в чому проблема?
Україна повідомила про наявність 17-ти зернових суден
в Одесі та околицях.
10 з них готові відчалювати найближчим часом.
Наразі чекають на підтвердження ООН та Туреччини,
які є гарантами безпеки.
Україна побоюється,
що ця подорож для кораблів стане «подорожжю в один кінець».
Росіяни неодноразово обстрілювали порти Одеси
і саме місто.
Україна замінувала вʼїзди у порти,
щоб захистити їх від російського вторгнення.
Виникає питання, наскільки безпечно зараз
організовувати експорт.
Анна Брюль і надалі інформуватиме нас про розвиток подій.
Є новини про новий масований обстріл Донеччини.
Москва і Київ притягують одне одного до відповідальності.
Відомо про загибель приблизно 50 українських військовополонених,
серед них також члени полку «Азов».
Табір полонених розташований на окупованій території,
тому наявні тільки російські відеоматеріали.
Москва вважає обстріли попередженням,
що Україну не зупинять навіть власні солдати.
Київ стверджує, що Москва так хоче приховати сліди
тортур і страт, які відбувалися у таборі військовополонених.
Німеччина постачала Україні важке озброєння
у невеликій кількості.
На черзі - танки для наведення мостів.
Поставка шести танків під назвою Biber
планується ще цього року,
ще десяти - наступного.
Про це заявило Міністерство оборони в Берліні.
Щоб належно підготуватися до зими,
треба якомога швидше заповнити газові сховища.
Від сьогодні діють суворіші правила.
Погляньмо на числа.
Нині газосховища Німеччини заповнені на 67,5%.
Міністерство економіки встановило нову проміжну ціль:
до 1 вересня рівень заповненості має сягнути 75%,
до 1 жовтня рівень має піднятися з 80 до 85%,
а до 1 листопада - з 90 до 95%.
Та наскільки реалістичні такі цілі?
Репортаж Олівера Гойхерта та Елізабет Шмідт.
Ситуація напружена. Візьмемо як приклад
громаду Реден, Нижня Саксонія,
де розташоване найбільше німецьке
сховище природного газу.
Однак і воно навіть наполовину не заповнене.
Кількість газу до осені має подвоїтися.
І хоча федеральний уряд вважає таку ідею реалістичною,
промисловість ставиться до цього скептично.
Навіть якщо зараз рівень заповнення сховищ зростає,
все ж нам не варто
піддаватися марним надіям.
Треба зачекати. Все залежить від погоди взимку
і від початку опалювального сезону.
Ситуацію ускладнює Росія.
Газопровід «Північний потік-1» постачає
тільки 20% від узгодженої кількості газу.
Хоча Німеччина купує природний газ у Нідерландів
та Норвегії, все ж потужності вичерпані.
Міністр економіки Габек не хоче допустити
зменшення кількості газу в сховищах.
Попри високі ринкові ціни на газ ми маємо запобігти
зменшенню кількості газу.
Не можна допустити, щоб на початку серпня
газосховища були заповнені на 90%, а потім раптом
наприкінці вересня - на 75%
через велику кількість охочих заробити.
Тому нові джерела газу дуже важливі.
Два з чотирьох терміналів зрідженого природного газу (LNG)
функціонуватимуть вже наприкінці року.
Один з них прибуде до Вільгельмсгафена.
Однак всі труднощі цим не подолати.
Ми вважаємо,
що без істотного заощадження в приватному секторі
нестачі не уникнути.
Крім того, не можна допустити
підвищення цін для домогосподарств.
Чи доведеться через високі ціни
регулювати потужність батарей?
Все залежить від кількості заощадженого газу влітку.
Щоб зменшити залежність від російського газу,
у Німеччині активно
шукають альтернативи.
Зараз працюють над побутовим біогазом.
Біоенергетична асоціація повідомляє,
що зараз біогаз забезпечує майже 10 млн
домогосподарств електроенергією,
і більше ніж мільйон домогосподарств - теплом.
Їх може стати більше.
Про значення біогазу розповість Олівер Дойкер.
Торстен Крузе - директор біогазової установки
у місті Роше в Нижній Саксонії.
Там енергію отримують з силосної кукурудзи,
буряків, рослинних залишків, гноївки та гною.
Під час їхнього бродіння виробляється газ,
який перетворюють в електроенергію для 4000
домогосподарств.
Відпрацьоване тепло заводу
використовують 1500 домогосподарств.
А незначна частина чистого газу потрапляє у мережу.
За годину наш завод продукує
три мегавати.
І цей результат ми могли легко подвоїти.
Навіть якщо брати до уваги тільки
завод біогазу у Нижній Саксонії,
то досить швидко можна замінити 20% газу,
який раніше імпортували з Росії.
У цьому переконана Державна асоціація
відновлюваної енергетики. Якби ж їм тільки дозволили.
Цьогоріч для нашого заводу було затверджено
певний обсяг біогазу,
який ми не маємо право порушувати.
Ми зробили б це з радістю,
адже у нас є запаси сировини,
Проте нам не дозволено,
тому що це суворо санкціонується.
Біогазові установки є прикладом
екологічної економіки замкнутого циклу.
В доповнення до вітру
та сонця вони завжди можуть виробляти енергію.
Уряд звинувачують
у марнуванні цього потенціалу.
Я впевнений, що незабаром ми дочекаємося рішення уряду
про скасування раніше ухваленого максимального
виробництва.
Оскільки зараз, на цьому етапі,
навіть якщо ми визначимо певні терміни виконання завдань,
ми все одно маємо бути гнучкими,
насамперед у використанні біогазових установок
як зараз, так і в майбутньому.
Проте Олаф Ліз не підтримує ідею засаджувати
більше енергетичних культур
і менше сільськогосподарських.
Варто зауважити, біогазові установки,
розташовані на всій території Німеччини,
можуть забезпечити теплом та електроенергією
чотири мільйони домогосподарств.
Перейдемо до новин світу.
Після візиту до Греції міністерка закордонних справ
прибула до Туреччини.
Бербок хотіла обговорити питання,
у розвʼязанні яких погляди країн не збігаються.
Як-от, права людини.
До того ж йдеться про конфлікт Туреччини й Греції,
двох країн НАТО, за території.
Бербок підтримує Грецію.
Сюжет Патриції Відемеєр.
Здавалося б, Бербок навідалася до друзів та країн НАТО,
але ця місія - ще те випробування.
Перша зупинка - Афіни.
Міністр закордонних справ
дружньо зустрічає Анналену Бербок,
але не забуває про репарації
за час німецької окупації у Другій світовій війні.
Греція очікує більше підтримки Німеччини
в непростих відносинах з Туреччиною.
Зокрема, не хоче, щоб Туреччині постачали
підводні човни.
Ці підводні човни означатимуть зміну балансу сил
на Східному Середземноморʼї.
Тому це загроза для нас.
Ба більше, попри те, що Туреччина є членом НАТО,
країна часто говорить про війну.
Як і два роки тому, Анкара знову хоче відправити кораблі
до грецької території для буріння газових свердловин.
І критикує дислокацію військ
на островах
у східній частині Егейського моря.
Реакція міністерки Бербок - чітка і зрозуміла.
Грецькі острови: Лесбос, Кос, Родос та інші -
територія Греції.
І ніхто не має права ставити це під сумнів.
Робимо висновок,
Німеччина солідарна з Грецією.
Міністерка закордонних справ
Бербок знає, що у розвʼязанні проблем біженців
і наслідків війни в Україні
їй потрібні обидві держави.
Тож бути посередницею між ними,
розв'язувати питання діалогом
і одночасно не зруйнувати відносини -
непросте випробування.
Сьогодні ввечері Бербок прибула до Стамбула.
Під час зустрічі міністерка поспілкувалася
з турецьким колегою про війну в Україні,
про досягнення перемирʼя
та тероризм.
Переговори тривають і далі.
Пресконференція Анналени Бербок
та її турецьких колег ще не завершилася.
Туреччина незадоволена.
Країна заявила, що Німеччина «втратила неупередженість»
у посередництві між Анкарою та Афінами.
Раніше Бернбурґ висловив претензії щодо AGS.
Приблизно рік тому
радикальний ісламський рух Талібан
захопив владу в Афганістані.
Побоювання підтвердились:
як повідомляє міжнародна правозахисна організація
Amnesty international,
права жінок і дівчат
були помітно обмежені талібами.
Зокрема, їм заборонено відвідувати
середні школи та університети.
Наша репортерка Катрін Айґендорф
побувала там.
Гусейн Кель, село на південній околиці Кабула.
Абдул Маджид, батько сімох дочок,
запросив нас до своєї оселі.
Чоловіку боляче усвідомлювати той факт,
що Талібан забрав у дівчат право на освіту.
Якщо таліби залишаться при владі, дівчата зможуть
відвідувати школу лише до шостого класу.
Ми нічого не можемо з цим вдіяти.
Відтоді, як самопроголошені «воїни Бога»
захопили владу рік тому,
економічне становище в сім'ї значно погіршилось.
Зарплати 48-річного чоловіка ледь вистачає,
щоб прогодувати сім'ю.
Четверо старших доньок ще відвідують
школу й мають плани на майбутнє.
Я запитала в них, ким вони хочуть стати.
Вчителькою.
Лікаркою.
Чому?
Лікарі допомагають людям.
Той факт, що дівчат та жінок Афганістану
позбавили права на освіту,
викликає все більше критики на міжнародному рівні.
Виконувач обов'язків міністра
інформаційної політики заперечує це.
Під час розмови він наполягає, що не хоче бачити
мене, жінку,
разом із собою в кадрі.
Я заперечую те, що наша країна не дбає про освіту.
Мільйони дівчат зараз навчаються
в найрізноманітніших навчальних закладах.
Жінкам Афганістану дуже не пощастило.
Через рік після захоплення влади Талібаном вони
втратили майже всі важко здобуті свободи і права.
Це може все більше перетворюватися на проблему
для країни.
Разом із питанням щодо майбутнього дочок
також саме існування родини Маджид стоїть на кону.
І вони не єдині.
З цієї причини багато афганців
критикують освітню політику Талібану.
Високі ціни на енергію, дорогі продукти:
Рівень липневої інфляції в Єврозоні
досяг нового максимуму - 8,9%.
Про це повідомила статистична організація Євростат.
Однак в Німеччині цей відсоток порівняно менший.
В країнах Балтії ціни відчутно зросли.
В Естонії, Латвії та Литві темпи інфляції сягнули
трохи більше 20%.
Поки в Єврозоні економіка зростає,
в Німеччині спостерігаємо застій.
Валовий внутрішній продукт порівняно
з попереднім кварталом не змінився,
повідомляє Федеральне статистичне відомство.
Попри всі суперечності, ринок праці
залишається стабільним.
У липні налічувалось 2,47 мільйони безробітних,
це на 107 тисяч більше, ніж у червні.
Причиною стало збільшення кількості
біженців від війни з України.
Квота зросла на 0,2 пункти, до 5,4%.
Порівняно з липнем минулого року
сьогодні безробітних менше на 120 000.
Ринок праці залишається стабільним,
попри коронавірус та війну в Україні.
І все ж можемо простежити очевидну зміну.
Вона стосується того, як і де, або, точніше,
звідки працюють люди.
Все більше й більше людей працюють віддалено.
Домашній офіс стає все популярнішим.
Як пандемія прискорює інновації,
розповість Штефан Шлессер.
Початок роботи за кухонним столом.
Карстен Бжескі - головний економіст ING Bank.
У його підпорядкуванні команда з понад 30 осіб.
Чоловік може складати гнучкий розпорядок дня
і сам вирішує, як часто їздити в офіс.
Його працівники також.
Мені не обов'язково знати,
де і як мої працівники виконують свою роботу.
Для мене важливо, щоб вони виконували свою роботу
і робили це дуже якісно.
Де і коли виконується робота, мені цілком байдуже.
Це можна побачити і в банку.
Сьогодні лише 25-30% усіх працівників
працюють в офісах ING Bank,
усі інші - в домашніх офісах.
Ми встановили, що продуктивність
залишилась на тому самому рівні,
або й навіть збільшилась.
По-друге, рівень захворюваності знизився,
дуже позитивний ефект
для нашої компанії.
І, по-третє, у результатах опитування ми бачимо,
що задоволеність працівників зросла.
Згідно з дослідженням, майже кожен четвертий
працівник у Німеччині
частково працює у власних чотирьох стінах.
Це тренд, який не зникне, кажуть експерти.
Компаніям, які без поважної причини не пропонують
роботу з дому,
буде надзвичайно важко найняти талановитих фахівців
і утримувати своїх працівників.
Робота з дому стає все більш популярною,
а багато опитувань показують,
що працівники готові змінити роботу,
якщо вони більше не матимуть можливості
працювати вдома.
Проте через роботу винятково вдома
втрачається особисте, контакт з колегами,
а також зв'язок з компанією.
Тому Карстен Бжескі
не хоче повністю відмовлятися від офісу в банку,
навіть якщо вдома найкраще.
Менше газу з Росії, менше ліків з Китаю та Індії.
Ще один урок кризових років:
якщо ви залежні від одного чи кількох виробників,
це може погано закінчитись.
Зараз спостерігається дефіцит сотень препаратів.
Наприклад, зараз, під час курортного сезону,
бракує незамінного в сімейній аптечці продукту:
засобу від лихоманки для дітей.
Анна Ґурт розповість детальніше.
Над смаком, який би подобався дітям, ще працюють,
незабаром препарат власного виробництва
буде готовий.
Адже засобів проти лихоманки,
які містять парацетамол та ібупрофен,
тут, як і скрізь, немає. Запасів також немає.
Нам ще не доводилось бачити
настільки критичну нестачу ліків.
Скрізь, де б ми не дізнавались, у виробника,
гуртових постачальників, різних фірм, ліків немає.
Небачена досі ситуація.
Основна причина дефіциту:
один із виробників зупинив виробництво
декілька місяців тому,
попит на товари інших виробників зріс настільки,
що деякі аптеки зараз просто порожні.
Проблеми з постачанням стали вже буденним
явищем для аптек.
Це проблема для аптекарів.
Загалом ситуація стає поступово
все гіршою і гіршою.
Ми залежні від продукції Китаю.
І якщо китайці не постачатимуть продукції,
тоді ми матимемо дефіцит.
Перші 42 повідомлення про проблеми з
постачанням були 2013 року,
а минулого року повідомлень було аж 381.
Все менше великих виробничих потужностей,
зокрема у Китаї та Індії,
виробляють активні речовини для медикаментів.
Важливо, що ціна є найнижчою.
Перемагає лише найдешевший товар.
А виробляти дешевий товар можливо лише тоді,
коли можна покрити всі витрати,
максимально обмежити всі ресурси.
Звичайно, це впливає на безпеку постачання.
Бьорн Шіттенгельм також закликає приділяти
більше уваги надійним ланцюжкам постачання.
А також повернути як мінімум
частину виробництва в Європу.
Ситуація із засобом проти лихоманки
восени може знову покращитися.
До того часу варто
запитувати в аптеках про аналоги.
Адже засоби можуть бути і власного виробництва.
Бракує не лише засобів від лихоманки,
також бракує й ліків для хронічно хворих.
Більше інформації ви можете знайти в Інтернеті
будь-коли в нашому додатку «ZDFheute».
Норберте, сьогодні важливий футбольний вечір,
але я маю не увазі не чемпіонат Європи в Англії,
а Кубок Німеччини з футболу.
І на початку гри Давида проти Ґоліафа є дещо,
що робить цей кубок таким захопливим:
Мюнхен 1860 проти Боруссії Дортмунд,
третя ліга проти віце-чемпіонів.
Катрін Мюллер-Гогенштайн зараз у Мюнхені:
чи почалась вже ця футбольна подія?
О, так.
Для Боруссії Дортмунд це буде справжнім
пекельним казаном.
На стадіоні збираються майже 15 000 вболівальників.
Відбувся і марш фанатів,
вони зібралися о 16:30, а потім пройшли
прямо на стадіон.
Востаннє обидві команди зустрічалися на полі
2013 року на Кубку Німеччини,
тоді Боруссія посприяла овертайму, але перемогла
з рахунком 2:0.
«Леви» вже тут, ми будемо ще в ефірі о 20:15
наживо з Мюнхена.
Дякую, Катрін. В неділю відбудеться
фінал чемпіонату Європи, на який усі чекали,
Англія проти Німеччини, перед 90 000 глядачами.
Поєдинок двох найкращих команд
і двох найкращих футболісток:
Бет Мід проти Александри Попп.
Німецька героїня чемпіонату Європи:
цілеспрямована не лише на полі,
також потрапляє у яблучко своїм гумором.
Ми просто хочемо пожартувати з того,
що відбувається в соцмережах.
Тому сьогодні з вами я, Александр,
і я щасливий бути тут.
Натякає на те, що багато хто вимагає її участі
у чоловічому чемпіонаті. Як бачимо, гумор
завжди з нею.
Шість разів німецька капітанка вже забила м'яча
на цьому чемпіонаті,
так само, як і найкраща англійська захисниця Бет Мід.
Але в одному вона випередила суперницю,
Попп використовує шаблони й поза полем.
Нідерландка Маріанна Вос
здобула перемогу на другому
етапі Тур де Франс для жінок.
35-річна жінка посіла перше місце
у 129-кілометровому спринті
і захистила свою жовту майку лідера.
Кращі німці на фініші: Ліан Ліпперт на 24 місці.
Завтра відбудеться королівський етап туру,
з трьома важкими гірськими заїздами.
Метеорологічна служба Німеччини попереджає
про сильні грози
зі зливами та сильними поривами вітру
на півночі Баварії.
Про погоду нам розповість Катя Горнеффер.
Дивіться в ефірі о пів на десяту «heute journal»
з Мітрієм Зіріним.
Зокрема, під час перерви на Кубку Німеччини з футболу.
До зустрічі в ефірі.
Доброго вечора.
В Німеччині тривають літні канікули.
І цього літа
ми часто спостерігаємо температури,
як у Середземномор'ї.
В самому Середземному морі
зараз дуже висока температура води,
від 26 до 29°C.
Наскільки приємнішими там є нічні температури,
в межах 11-17°C.
Прогнозуємо дуже сильні грози.
Можуть пройти повені та сильні зливи,
особливо в Саксонії, Тюрингії та Баварії.
Завтра ці сильні зливи поступово перемістяться на схід.
Найспокійніше буде між
Берліном й узбережжям Балтійського моря
та між островом Нордернай та Верхнім Рейном.
Під щільними хмарами зі зливами та грозами
температури сягатимуть від 20
до 22°C, як і на узбережжі.
Найтепліше буде у Верхньому Рейні,
там прогнозуємо 30°C.
В неділю прогнозуємо багато сонця,
лише на північному заході йтимуть перші зливи.
Температури трохи підвищаться.
А після мінливого понеділка
на нас чекає наступна коротка хвиля спеки.
На один-два дні температури знову підвищаться
до 38 °C.
Гарного вечора!